Hallo Wolfgang. Hallo Stefan. Wo sind wir hier? Diesmal in der echten Garderobe.
Wir sind wirklich in der Garderobe. Draußen ist schon das Publikum.
Es tobt schon fast, kann man sagen. Und wir gehen gleich raus,
denn es ist wieder Live-Salon in der Käs in Frankfurt. Richtig. Was machen wir hier?
Karneval. Die Leute haben unser Cover ja schon gesehen. Ja.
Ich habe mir tatsächlich die Mainzer Fernsehsitzung Mains by Mains angesehen.
Und zwar ist das ja eine Sendung, die sagt, hier findet Politik statt.
Und da dachte ich mir, ja eine politische Karnevalssendung, die muss ich mir
doch unbedingt ansehen.
Und es ist eine Sendung, die natürlich die Mitte der Bevölkerung erreichen will.
Und im Saal sind auch Politiker, die zuhören.
Das heißt, das sind wirklich Clips für die Ewigkeit zum Teil, hat man den Eindruck.
Aber auch grauenhafte, um es gleich
dazu zu sagen. und ich habe noch Clips mitgebracht über Superjachten.
Denn auch da gibt es eine neue Bescheidenheit. Davon werde ich dir erzählen.
Neue Bescheidenheit bei den Superjachten? Ja. Okay, gut.
Wir gucken, bevor Wolfgang Karneval guckt, Karneval. Wir hören.
Es sind ja Podcasts. Männer machen Podcasts. Wir hören uns an,
wie Männer diese Podcasts beginnen.
Wie sie uns sagen, worüber sie reden. Wie sie mit Gesprächspartnern umgehen
und so weiter und so fort.
Sie retten die Demokratie dabei, nehme ich an. Es geht immer um die Demokratie.
Also wer sich fragt, warum redet Gordon Repinski im Springer-Podcast Politico mit Krah von der AfD,
aber nur für 200 Sekunden und was kann man in 200 Sekunden verhandeln?
Der kriegt heute die Antwort.
Ja, ich bin sehr gespannt darauf. Du hast dich da durch 100 Stunden durchgekämpft.
Respekt, in Mainzburg Mainz dauerte nur 4 Stunden.
Also das war nur und eine geringe Vorbereitung für mich. Vier Stunden,
die ich, ansonsten ist ja so, du bringst politischen Kram mit.
Und ich lasse mich dann überraschen und stelle fest, das ist ja ganz schön interessant, was du geguckt hast.
Jetzt, wo du die Karnevalssitzung geguckt hast, konnte ich dir zurückmelden, habe ich schon gesehen.
Ja, ich bin total erschrocken darüber, ja. Ich erkläre gleich, warum.
Ich finde es auch ungewöhnlich, dass ich die schon gesehen habe, aber es ist, wie es ist.
Außerdem sagen wir euch, was wir im nächsten Salon lesen.
Genau. Es ist ein Buch von Liz Pelley, kennt man sie?
Nein, sie ist eine Tech-Journalistin, Expertin, die sich mit Spotify auseinandergesetzt
hat und sehr tief eingestiegen ist. Das Buch heißt Mood Machine.
Kann man sich schon denken, wo es dahin geht, also welche Stimmung da über eine
Maschine hergestellt wird.
Der Untertitel lautet The Rise of Spotify and the Costs of...
Playlist. Es geht also darum, wie Spotify unser Hören verändert hat,
die Musik verändert hat.
Es geht um AI-Musik natürlich auch und wie diese Plattform so überdominant geworden
ist und eigentlich unsere ganze Popkultur und unseren Gemütshaushalt auch mitbestimmt.
Deshalb Mood Machine und ich erwarte ihr Großes von diesem Buch.
Sehr gut, ich auch. Ich bin sehr gespannt, denn solcher Untertitel,
die Kosten der perfekten Playlist.
Denkt man zuerst so, ist das jetzt so untertitelwürdig? aber man ahnt schnell,
ja, doch, die Kosten, die Perfektion und die Playlist.
Ich werde wahrscheinlich dann, wenn wir das im Salon besprechen,
vorher schon aus Athen berichtet haben.
Ich habe mir die alten heiligen und eben politischen Städten mal angeschaut.
Und das Zentrum von allen ist das Dionysos-Theater.
Was jetzt für mich bedeutet, das nächste Jahr wahrscheinlich bin ich heuristisch
nur auf der Suche nach dem Abklatsch vom Abklatsch von Abklatsch und der Renaissance
des Abklatsch des Dionysos-Theater. Da sind wir mit diesem Buch,
da ich ja eh gerne über die Gemütszustände und Gefühle, Gefühlshaushalte rede.
Ich bin sehr gespannt. Also wir werden dann weiter einen dionysischen Stefan erleben.
Ich mache den apolinischen Wolfgang dazu. Mal sehen, das ist ja der alte Konflikt. Mal schauen.
Jedenfalls freuen wir uns, wenn ihr den Live-Sanon hören wollt und wenn ihr
dazu dann ein Abo abschließt.
Das ist ganz einfach machbar über Steady.
Man geht auf unsere Homepage neuzwanziger.de.
Dort findet man einen goldenen Button, klickt darauf und kommt dann gleich zu
Steady. Und ab drei Euro im Monat ist man dann dabei.
Und es gibt natürlich noch die Möglichkeit über Patreon und über Apple direkt
ist auch der Live-Salon-Buchbau.
Natürlich auch alle anderen Salons, die schon stattgefunden haben, kann man dann hören.
Genau. Jeder hört, wie er mag. Aber wir bevorzugen, wenn ihr Steady-Kunden werdet.
Das ist für alle am einfachsten, am billigsten und am vollständigsten.
Dann sehen wir uns gleich live auf der Bühne. So, ihr seid. Bis gleich.
Guten Abend.
Hallo.
Man sieht schon, Wolfgang, grau, grau, dunkelblau, weiß, ich,
schwarz. Es ist noch Karneval in Frankfurt.
Ja.
Wir nennen es hier Faschig.
Heute wird es närrisch.
Närrisch.